the first diagram is what you've been
seeing over and over again of particle
body object movie in a circle on a flat
horizontal sort of table or something
like that and then you've got a stream
and your particle is moving around it
around in uniform circular motion so we
have seen this many many times but okay
however this is always a bit weird like
what is this particle and what's so
special at this string that for some
reason it's just like this Reed magic oh
it's just going round and round because
because someone said it was okay what's
making it do that this is actually not
very normal what's far more normal is if
this string is lifted up off the table
can you imagine lifting in fact let's
just go to door so here's my table right
what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna lift
the center of um um this is point here
I'm gonna move it so the strees actually
up above this table so here you use my
new table right now lifting up the
string so it's sort of up here okay now
if from this point I get this thing to
keep on going around right like so he's
he's the new center of bushin okay he
can still move in a circle he's still
move in a circle it could still be
beautiful circular motions but the shape
that gets traced out the shape that gets
traced out as you can see is it cone so
that's why we call this a conical
pendulum okay so this has its own sort
of there are lots of interesting things
about which is why we sort of pull it up
as a special scenario so what's a
natural question to ask in mechanics
about a physical situation so the
natural question what is what is special
about mechanics it's now forces it's all
about forces okay so let's try to
understand what forces are operated you
okay
because now I'm now literally in 3d like
I'm not just like sort of 3d of them
I've really got to worry about this okay
I've got to figure out what's happening
up and down and then I'm gonna figure
out horizontally on this table okay so
what I'm gonna add onto here is that
I've got a um a weight for spilling down
mg I've got a reaction force coming up
off the table and then I've got the
resultant force that sum on horizontally
which is moving this thing around okay
now think about this this guy here mg
right we're just heading down this way
if I have I'm now gonna redraw this but
with with less like fluff around it okay
if I have this looking side on he's a
right angle he is where my object is he
is the center of motion over here we
know we've got mg heading downwards like
this sorry I should draw it longer but
it's a run out of space okay you've got
the thing holding it into the motion is
the tension of this stream that's I'm
gonna call that T for tension and it's
pulling toward where you're holding the
string this weight is going with
okay now it's on a table it's on a table
so therefore how much movement is
happening on an up-down vertical axis
there's no motion right in terms of
up-down
so therefore this weight force and the
part of this tension think projectile
motion should think resolving forces the
part of this tension that's pointing
directly upwards they should be exactly
balanced does that make sense there has
to be balance this positive and this
negative have to equal zero because
otherwise it would actually be moving up
and down okay so what I'm gonna do is
I'm not put a line up here this is why I
said this really should be longer
because they've balanced this line up
here is the vertical component of the
tension force okay I'll have a training
with you they don't have a horizontal
component now we were just talking about
this vertical component nothing's
happening there's this horizontal
component the horizontal component is
what's making it move in a circle right
it's moving this way toward the center
right so that's the direction it's
facing you okay to work out everything
remember we projectile motion I said if
you're gonna resolve forces you need to
know of course what angle you're facing
it right because if you fire if that
angle versus that angle s that angle you
will get different amounts contributing
to vertical or horizontal okay so this
angle up the top we tend to call fides
we it's often called a semi vertical
angle because you're sort of half of
this code
now that's theater over there that means
you also theater over here because of
alternate angles or these parallel
vertical lines so now can you help me
work out what is the vertical component
of the force from this attention
industry
what sort of ratio we're gonna use now
so this is a vertical component here's
theta
I'm adjacent and the tension is
hypotenuse right so cos theta is this on
this right the vertical component like
that so if I just want the vertical
component then that's going to be t cos
theta just multiply both sides by
that okay by the same logic the
horizontal component is uh yes correct
but that's because of where we're degree
angles wrong yeah okay so far so good so
now I want to try and bring all this
together I should take what's ballocks
and what's creating a beautiful circular
motion so let's do the easy bit first
vertically I've said that these two
things are balanced I could just say
they're equal to each other
but I've already mentioned before just
my personal preference is to say look if
this thing is positive because you know
away from the earth I'm not a positive
I'm gonna call this a negative so I
prefer to write it like this that shows
there's a net force of zero
it also shows what's going on and what's
going down as opposed to just say are
they're the same value but either way
which is which okay so from there I'm
just going to say yes okay this is gonna
be important for me later so I'm just
gonna label that it's a greater one now
what about horizontally on the table
what's happening there is a uniform
circular motion and I know if a uniform
circular motion and that the resultant
force toward the center of that motion
is negative or sorry I just said towards
the center so that's just going to be
the magnitude will just be M R per meter
square right they should be equal to
this does that make sense
so I'm going to say horizontally T sine
theta equals M R Omega square
yep I'm gonna say
think think so yeah you're right so they
are they're headed this way right T side
theaters going this way towards like the
center of the stream okay but in order
for uniform circular motion to be taking
place it has to be going they have to be
going that way which is one of the
lovely things like this is about saying
oh these are balanced that's right this
is more about saying this produces that
right now you will also notice I've got
T something here please do not do not
draw an arrow here and say Mr Omega
squared okay because there's no force
happening here it's the resultant force
okay it's the resultant force so it's
just like you wouldn't say on here you
wouldn't draw a zero force somewhere
because there isn't a zero force zero
force is the resultant force in the same
way M R Omega squared is what results
from this guy this is the only thing
happening horizontally so it must be
equivalent to that so make sense this is
also important so I'm going to call it
question - okay wonderful
so how am I going to get out of this R
we're trying to understand the forces
right so what's the tension in the
string the tension in the string I've
got two ways of sameness I could stand
it in terms of cos theta mg right or I
could stay it in terms of M R Omega
squared which do you think is going to
be more useful to me yeah mi Omega
squares can be much more useful because
then I can say ah what how will how will
the force change something like this I'm
just going to divide through this is a
superior way of stating the tension
because I can now understand what
happens to tension as the speed of the a
the angular velocity changes as the
radius of my circle changes and as the
mass changes whereas if I read this one
T equals mg on cos theta like what
gravity is the same thing it always is
the mass is going to be constant I
assume and then there's not that much
that's interesting compared to this so
far so good
okay so I've got my attention but I'm
gonna go a little bit further than this
okay because ah like R is this thing
here right it's not even here to this
situation and it can change actually as
you
see shortly what's much more important
to me is the length of this string and
how it relates I happen to have a
shorter string or a longer string okay
so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to try
and relate this length with radius and
all that kind of all those measurements